good evening it is an act of aggression
condemned as a barbaric attack on an
independent democratic country cities
have been bombarded towns devastated and
countless lives have been lost and now
growing evidence of war crimes is
emerging evidence dismissed by russia as
a sham tonight in his first british
broadcast interview since the war began
i speak to the man who does much of the
talking for vladimir putin his spokesman
dmitry peskov he joins me live from his
office in moscow and thank you very much
for being with us first of all um
do you accept that the first weeks of
this invasion have not
gone according to plan for president
putin
well first of all i would rather
disagree with your qualification of what
is going on
you didn't mention uh the the
qualification of special military
operation
and you didn't say a word about the
reasons for the special military
operation
uh you because it's a war isn't it it's
not a special military operation it is a
full-scale
illegal
war
it's a very serious operation
with with the
quite heavy consequences yes
i would i would like to start to start
with the reason of this operation
actually it's very important or to
remind you
uh
2014 this is the year when the legal
history of ukraine was changed
during uh an illegal coup
and after that ukraine has started to
become
uh an anti-russian center
everything that that occurred in ukraine
was aimed against our country
and uh during last couple of decades
actually we were concerned about our
security
nato after the collapse of the soviet
union started to move towards our body
uh our boundaries yeah and we were we
were really nervous about that but
ukraine but ukraine let's be honest
about this ukraine
posed
no threat to russia and nato is a
defensive organization that also
poses no threat to russia and just my
point at the beginning was that you have
retreated the reason i said it's not
going to plan is you've retreated from
the capital
president zielenski is still in power
you've lost
thousands of troops you've lost six
generals
uh hundreds of tanks and other equipment
it's
it's a humiliation really isn't it
no no
it's a wrong understanding of what is
going on
well what is wrong about what i've just
said
okay well nearly everything
nearly everything well you've lost
thousands of troops yeah let's go
through it you've lost thousands of
troops how many troops have you lost we
have we have we have significant losses
of troops and uh it's it's it's a huge
tragedy for us
uh now about two regions kiev and the
turning of regions
uh so actually the troops were really
withdrawn from that region as an act of
a good will
during the negotiations between two
delegations russian and ukrainian
delegation
and it wasn't it was an act of a good
will just to
to uh well to to to lift tension from
those regions and in order to show that
russia is really
ready to create comfortable
conditions for continuation of
negotiation but it's just not true is it
because you continued if it was if it
was a a measure of good will why then
did you continue to bombard
mariupol in the way that you have to
devastate that city if you really wanted
to facilitate peace talks you would have
had a ceasefire but you carried on
bombarding mariupol and shelling kharkiv
and other places so it's it's not really
true is it
if you let me i'll try to explain
well first of all mariupol is a part of
lugansk people's republic you know we
recognize them as an independent state
and actually the premier goal of the
operation was to
uh was to to to to assist those people
of two people's republics
that were suffering for eight years from
heavy shelling from ukrainian military
people and by the way during those eight
years no one would
would
mention that
would mention those atrocities no no way
that's just no one in great britain even
if it was true that doesn't justify a
full-scale evasion invasion does it i
mean let's keep this in
proportion i mean
are
it's part of ukraine are you determined
to take mario paul whatever the human
cost whatever the cost in civilian life
mary opal is going to be uh liberated
from uh nationalistic battalions
and uh we hope it will happen sooner
than later
in liberation you describe it as
liberation so the pounding of mario paul
the pounding of civilian buildings the
pounding of a hospital that's liberation
is it
well hospital hospital was a fake
hospital was a fake and
uh we have very serious reasons to
believe that it was a fake and we insist
on that
this is number one number two well
you did say that one of the the the
famous photograph or infamous photograph
of a woman on a stretcher
which you said was a she you said she
was an actor she turned out a doctor
told us later to have died she told us
to
she died so let's not talk about
that i mean how many civilians let me
ask you this how many civilians do you
think have died in
ukraine so far
i don't want to operate any figures that
are not confirmed or double confirmed
we have we have to be very careful we
have to be very careful in pronouncing
any figures because we're living in a uh
during a days of of fakes fakes and lies
that we let me tell you this
every day let me tell you this so your
u.n u.n ambassador has said there are no
credible reports of civilian casualties
and as regards butcher according to your
ministry of defense on april the third
and i quote not a single local resident
has suffered from any violent action
while russia was in control i mean
do you really expect the world to
believe that
we insist on that we insist on that and
we insist that the whole situation the
situation is butcher is a well-staged
uh
insinuation nothing else
so let me just show you those four
people those poor people and we're
seeing dead bodies there yeah and those
dead bodies there were not victims of
russian military personnel you see this
is astonishing
for you to talk like this let me just
show you this satellite image from uh
butcher on the outskirts of
kiev and this is an image taken on the
28th of february
we have geolocated it to yabalanska
street in butcher before russia had
control of the area it's a normal
looking street let's compare it to an
image of the exact same location
on the 19th of march just a couple of
days
after russia had taken control of the
area and now you see the shadows bodies
strewn
uh along the street and we know their
bodies from this video
speeches we know those monks are
supposed to because we know their bodies
from this video released i'm showing now
on social media on the 1st of april
which we've geolocated as well
we have blurred the bodies for
viewers and you can see this body is in
the same place as the ones seen in the
satellite image the body hasn't moved
the car drives along further you can see
stops at two more bodies again matching
the position of the ones in that
satellite
image and so it continues
with everybody on the street and
you maintain that all this was staged
you're talking about a fake
this shows that dead bodies appeared
while you control the area russian
troops
killed those people didn't they
if you have another 20 or to 30 minutes
i will explain step by step why it all
fakes
if you have this additional time let's
go on i will tell you
you're saying it's fake so there's not
much point going on but we've verified
it we've geolocated it
we've got the dates from the satellite
we know pretty well we know pretty well
the company that uh that has supplied
international community with these
satellite pictures this is a mixer
company that is you know in a very tight
cooperation with pentagon with the
pentagon
and uh yeah it's interesting it's
interesting to know and what you would
probably be uh
interesting to know that uh they don't
have actually exact dates on their on
their uh footage on their satellite
images so it's it's impossible to to
allocate
an exact date
of uh those satellite pictures okay
let's have a look
we still insist that those pictures
were made after prussian troops were
withdrawn from that area okay well what
about this one then because our team has
also verified this next video to early
march in the same area of boot show and
here we see a woman
with a bike named today as arena
filipina
walking along uh yabalanska street when
russian troops were in control
around the corner is an armored vehicle
identified by our team
as a russian military
vehicle so the russians are there you
can see the vehicle fire a shot which
creates a plume of smoke exactly
where irina was standing with her bike
now after the after let me finish if i
could just finish miss sorry after the
russians have withdrawn this video
geolocated to the exact same spot showed
arena lying
dead on the ground so there can be no
real doubt surely that this
uh shows russian troops killing a
civilian yeah it's right i appreciate it
people are more specific i'll appreciate
if you could be more specific how could
you exactly identify the russian tank or
whatever what was saying why do you
think it was russian okay well i think
we we got a still that shows the russian
tower you can see if you look at that
you can see the v marking
clearly on the side but those are not
the tanks that we're shooting that
suggests
different positions they are they are
the exact same
uh
armored vehicles that were on that
street i mean look we've verified
right now
what you're showing right now are not
the exact tank
that was shooting
you have to be very careful you have to
be very careful in what you are showing
just not too exactly the same armored
vehicle i mean
so you deny that that happened you're
denying it's happened and you're saying
it's being faked basically it's some
sort of conspiracy is that right
we deny that russian military
can have something in common with these
atrocities and with dead bodies that
were shown on the streets of butcher
so let's just
be clear here what you are saying to the
world what you're saying to
ukrainians what you're saying to
let's face it the relatives of those
victims that we've just seen there and
what you're saying to russians your own
people is that this is fabricated
it is fake and that is some sort of
huge
conspiracy a propaganda
stunt i mean do you
do you realize how grotesque that sounds
well it's not a conspiracy actually it's
a bold fake it's a bold fake and we've
been speaking about that for a couple of
days but no one would listen to us we've
been presenting very detailed
explanations on various various internet
resources if you're interested in that
we'll provide you with those internet
resources but but to say it's a fake
you're suggesting it's a conspiracy
between satellite imagery companies
between ukrainians between all the
western media i mean
you're suggesting
it is a conspiracy that's exactly what
you're saying
well of course it can be a play of fakes
it can be a play of lies okay you can
attach any any date
to a picture
that was made through satellite
okay and then what about well we have to
we have to doubt sometimes i mean you
cannot be without any investigation but
you doubt all the time i'm so sure okay
so blaming
everything on russia
well let me put this to you then human
rights watch
the organization they've already
documented uh documented
hundreds of apparent
war crimes and these include
i've got it here repeated rape of a
woman in front of her child after her
husband was killed other cases of rape
two cases of summary execution one of
six men
the other of one man
other cases of torture unlawful violence
threats against civilians i've got the
dates i've got the
witness statements we can go through it
if you want but these are documented
killings
with witness evidence and corroborated
by the way today
by amnesty international
and
we've and we've yet to discover what's
happening in
mario poll
i mean don't you see it's just
preposterous to
sort of issue a blanket
denial of all these things
it should all be very thoroughly
uh investigated i agree with you but at
the same time
we have even the bigger amount of uh
[Music]
of
eyewitnesses and people who took part in
the
various situations and
in mariopol in in butcher and other
other towns of ukraine
they were uh
they were telling us the terrible
stories of
those nationalistic battalion
battalion military military people
torturing people not letting them
leave the town
not letting them uh
go out of the town flee the town so we
we also have these eyewitnesses
so i mean
but you don't you don't want to listen
to them
we do we've just been carrying a story
this afternoon about claims of
uh ukrainian
walk i spoke to the
chief prosecutor of ukraine on this
program the other day
and she said that all
all war crimes would be investigated and
all the evidence would be passed on to
the international criminal court the
difference the difference is one we are
interested we have a
we also collect evidence and proofs
for
crimes that were committed by
nationalistic battalions but the
difference is one of scale but it is
also that they are agreeing to
investigate you are saying it is not
true it is a fake before you've even
investigated
well
we have to say that it's not true
because we're hearing that everything is
blamed on russia
and we we we completely disagree with
that
and by the way i would have a suggest a
humble suggest to you a suggestion
if you make a story about
crimes in ukraine and if you speak to
ukrainian prosecutor general why don't
you speak to russian prosecutor general
to make an objective picture to present
two sides we'd love to do that okay okay
we will do that let's just suppose then
that you are
you know what you are saying is right
and that you have not your troops have
not committed
these crimes will you presumably then
you will happily cooperate with the
international criminal court if you're
not guilty of any of these things
presumably you will cooperate with the
international criminal court
even if you don't recognize that we do
not support and we do not recognize
international criminal court and we are
not the the only country in the world
who are doing that
so uh this is number one and we are
interested in uh really independent
and then the objective investigation of
all the crimes
but we want just to to
we we want to understand what could be
the format of such an investigation
because we we have a bitter experience
of international investigations like
with the
uh with the grounded korean aircraft
uh international investigation and we
were not we were not let into that
investigation so we cannot consider it
to be objective so
there are other special tribunals that
you could cooperate with my only point
is that if you haven't done this
then why don't you just
cooperate with the tribunals or the
international criminal
court
well we're not speaking any tribunals we
don't know about the existence of
tribunals
and i repeat who do not recognize
international court
let me let me put this to you you deny
responsibility then quite clearly
what you can't deny is that civilians
many civilians including women and
children have died as a result of this
onslaught and they would be alive
today had you not invaded
ukraine i think it's 142 children
so far you you yourself have children
you have a young daughter
when you see the images how how does it
make you feel how do you sleep at night
it's not about my sleep at night
actually
and this is about
this is about
ukrainian military and eu ukrainian
nationalistic
military personnel
trying to use civil
civil people
as a shield as a civil civil shield so
they are covering themselves
with civil people and not letting them
flee the town or fleet they flee the
city and from the very beginning
russian military
uh
were never shelling
civil objects they were just aiming and
using high uh precision missiles
um
to to uh to attack
military infrastructure of ukraine
because
well sir forgive me for interrupting but
there must have been a lot of ukrainian
military in a lot of civilian buildings
then because our reporters have been out
and about in many of these towns and
cities exactly this is this one no the i
mean it is defies belief that many of
the targets that we've seen destroyed
are military
uh targets but i was talking to you
really not as a kremlin spokesman i was
talking to you
you know as a father as a human being
what when you see these images
how do you sleep at night that that is
it was that was really my question
that's a tragedy there's a tragedy and
uh
our military are doing their best
to to bring an end to that operation
and we do hope that in coming days in
in in foreseeable future this operation
will reach
its goals or will finish it by the
negotiations between russian and
ukrainian delegation
i mean do you think this can possibly
end
in a negotiation or talks after what has
happened
it can it can it will strongly depend on
the
uh
so on consistency of ukrainian position
and to what extent they will be ready to
they will be ready to meet uh to meet
our conditions
boris johnson has said that russia's and
i quote this is a quote russia's
despicable attacks on innocent civilians
in ur pin and butcher are yet more
evidence that putin and his army are
committing war crimes in ukraine we will
not rest until
justice is
served what's your message to boris
johnson
well uh he's very loud in his rhetorics
about russia from the very beginning of
the operation
so uh in our understanding he's rather
not constructive in his attitude
[Music]
we have never heard any any uh similar
rhetorics coming from boris johnson
during last eight years
when people in donbass were killed by
ukrainian nationalists
when they were heavily bombarded and
shelled
by heavier artillery
we have never heard a word coming from
mr johnson but it is scarcely comparable
does does
in light of what mr johnson has said
does mr putin worry about
ending up in a war crimes court
no he's not
have you talked to him about that does
he realize that it's a possibility
well uh
we don't see any possibility for that
but you have spoken about it have you
we've read lots of reports coming from
various countries
uh politologists and and
so-called specialists in russia
discussing such a possibility but we
don't consider it this this possibility
to be to be realistic
you see one of the problems with these
blanket
denials is that
isn't the problem for you and for mr
putin that
very few people outside russia
believe a
a single word that you say about all
this
uh why do you think it's it's it's a few
people it's a great amount of people
it's a great amount of people who
understand who understand concerns of
russia
and who have been understanding those
concerns during last couple of decades
and the world you have to understand
that the world is bigger
than europe and the united states and
great britain it's much bigger
is it but
so but i mean in the last hour you've
just been kicked off the un human rights
council so that is what much of the
world thinks about
about russia and about
the alleged war crimes coming out now
we're sorry about that and we'll
continue to defend our interests using
every
possible legal means
we'll continue to defend our interests
and to explain ourselves
the problem with the
the the lies that many international
leaders are accusing you of is it's not
new is it i mean look
you can look just recently at the lies
from
russia just the recent ones the
ukrainians you say shot down malaysian
airlines mh17
in 2014 the syrian opposition gassed
their own people the white helmets in
syria are terrorists who belong to
al-qaeda navalny putin's opponent
collapsed because of his medication not
because he was
poisoned the gru agents who were in
salisbury came to
see a cathedral
in 2014 again there are no russian
troops in crimea or in donbass and then
just a few weeks ago we are not going to
invade ukraine i mean none of those none
of those are true are they none of those
are true which one of those is that
which one of those is true
let's start from the very beginning what
was number one uh ukrainians uh you say
the ukrainians shot down malaysian
airlines mh17
in 2014. i mean you're not going to tell
me that that's true there are lots of
there are lots of evidence there are
lots of technical calculations
and they were all submitted to the court
in the hague
uh
there is a huge deficit deficit of of
proofs and technical data in the
uh in the court and there are uh
different points of view and the gi
agents in salisbury came to see the
cathedral i mean look the problem here
is a problem
of trust that people don't trust what
you say
you are a major country
hugely important culturally hugely
important historically
and
people now
don't believe a word the leadership
says that is a problem isn't it
which people
many of the international leaders
most of the west many of the
international leaders
many of them yes they say that they
don't believe
but many of the leaders believe and they
tend to
they tend to to explore they tend to
listen to our point of view
and we find their position much more
constructive and much more attractive
for us
but it's a problem in any dialogue any
future negotiations
that people
don't trust you particularly over
nato i mean vladimir putin embarked on
this military operation
basically
saying it was to counter partly it's
partly to counter the expansion of nato
and eastern europe well
nato has more troops now in eastern
europe germany is increasing its defense
spending i mean nato is stronger
now than it was
it's stronger not weaker
yeah and thus we have to rebalance the
situation and we tell we have to take
additional measures to ensure
our own security because we still we are
deeply convinced that nato nato is a
machine for confrontation it's not a
peaceful alliance it was tailored for
confrontation
and the main purposes of its existence
to confront and to confront our country
this is very unfortunate situation but
we have to take it into account you see
nato is a defensive
organization and finland
finland and sweden
finland has an 800-mile border with your
country they now want to join
nato as a result of all this what would
what would russia do if
if finland and sweden joined
nato we'll have to we'll have to
rebalance the situation i repeat again
and then we'll have to
uh we'll have to to to
to make our western western flank
uh
more more sophisticated into in terms of
ensuring our security but when you say
rebalance i mean president putin has
warned of
serious military and political
consequences what i just wonder what
that means
well we'll have to you know it's
everything about mutual deterring
mutual deterring and should one side
should one side and we consider nato to
be one side
um should one side be more powerful than
the other
especially in terms of nuclear
arms
then it will constitute a threat for the
whole architecture of security
and
it will take us to take additional
measures
um additional measures to strengthen
our potential
but but we do just very quickly on that
uh finally would you consider that an
existential threat because
that is you have said it would take an
existential threat to use
nuclear weapons which you've just
mentioned uh what exactly
another another enlargement of nato
you would consider that an existential
threat
no i don't think so right
would you consider pressure on your
economy or you know
sanctions that you deemed were to
to wreck your economy topple even top of
the regime would you consider that an
existential threat
well no no we've been living under under
sanctions for for a
couple of decades and we we actually we
actually have got accustomed to that
situation and uh uh
well we we we've started to prepare
ourselves for these
sanctions uh
a year ago a year ago and so now of
course we are in a very tight situation
in terms of economy
but our economy is still on its feet
and we are
quite quite
well
uh we're we're safe maybe not safe and
sound but we're safe in terms of economy
in terms of macro stability
and we're trying to and we even we're
trying to take advantage out of this
situation
uh giving a boost to to development of
our productive sector of our
national technologies and so on and so
and just finally um you've accr accused
ukraine
of being a fascist
uh regime but isn't it russia that is an
increasingly
looking like a
fascist state all the hallmarks of
fascism the shutting down of all
opposition the
strict censorship of the media the
sinister zed sign that is
um appearing and just the climate of
fear doesn't that all have a feeling of
of fascism about it
no well i consider it quite unacceptable
to to speak about
in that way about my country
uh
no
the answer is definitely no
the answer is no and uh
asking this question
i would suggest that you just recall
last last
eight years with nasa's demonstrations
on the streets of kiev on the streets of
velvet
with people
who were parts of nasa's regiments
during the second world war
carrying nazi nazi signs and nazi flags
and uh
performing nazi nazi nazi navy
what i don't know the english word
yeah but those nazi demonstrations they
well it was a reality it was a reality
on the streets of ukrainian cities but
the the last election the nazi the far
right parties barely won
two percent of the vote i mean you've
got to keep this in proportion look my
final question
is this what is to come because only
vladimir putin knows that uh presumably
more bombardments presumably
more death who knows maybe more
war crimes my final question is this
you know you've ripped away the future
of two countries
immediate future for two countries
russia your own country and ukraine and
my final question is is it all
worth it honestly is it all worth it
the whole story is about future
is about guaranteeing our future
just imagine a situation where a member
of nato ukraine
thinking about returning of crimea
attacks russia and detects russian
crimea
and using an article number five for
nato charter
nato countries possessing nukes
will have to defend ukraine yeah
it should be a third world war
and what is being done
is to save
from any potential threat of such a war
but it was never going to happen was it
like that but listen mr peskov uh
appreciate your time thank you very much
you